in these cities they don't give security
or safety
in these cities they fail spectacularly
when it comes to education specific
example
the city of baltimore 13 public high
schools
you want to venture a guess what
percentage in the 13
schools not 13 kids 13 public high
schools
what percentage of kids in those schools
and you don't have to answer it's not a
trick question
i'll i'll ballpark it i'll try just to
see do you believe
are proficient in math and reading
so for a guy that is governing like a
conservative that's that's pretty
obvious at this point one of the things
that we've talked about a couple of
times on your show is what's happening
in portland in seattle
in chicago in new york just the crazy
situations of violence and
murder and everything else because of
these progressive policies
which by the way years ago well well
before i knew you when i would flick on
your show
you were basically the only guy that was
talking about
the the black on black crime in chicago
and nobody and everyone would
what would they do they would call you
racist for it for even bringing it up
you'd say well 30 black people
died this weekend and they would call
you the racist for it
um but are you are you concerned at all
that that
optics-wise when trump then sends in uh
the national guard and we get federal
troops and these things
that this is playing into the hand that
oh well you see
he's he's the authoritarian he's the guy
that wanted to throw all the
all the federal troops into the cities
well when obama said this week that
federal troops
are using tear gas and batons
on peaceful protesters that's not true
and in spite of all the video evidence
of jerry nadler saying
this is a myth he actually said or who
would ever
think that a major party
presidential candidate would say the
words the police or the enemy
like what and supporting defunding the
police
i mean joe biden has yet to say a
good thing about the 99 percent of
policemen and women that protect and
serve their cities
all of them put their lives on the line
for all of us every single day
and so you you ask a great question
uh donald trump has not sent in the
national guard unless they request it
he's been begging new york city and
chicago
and portland and seattle begging them
let us help you restore law and order
and safety and security you can't pursue
happiness
dave rubin without law and order and a
safe community
if you're a one-year-old shot in a park
in new york dead in a stroller
an eight-year-old little girl killed in
atlanta because the
her mom made a wrong turn into the chop
zone near where the wendy's that street
had been taken over a new autonomous
zone
um and that little girl in the back of
the car
died after getting shot in the head or a
seven-year-old beautiful girl
in chicago died on the fourth of july
weekend
while at her grandmother's house you
know playing on the fourth of july
or horace lorenzo anderson
jr 19 years old and his father that
heart-wrenching interview that i had
with him
um it killed me because my my kids are
18 and 21.
anyway so the answer is he's offering
now that's separate and apart from the
we're talking about a hundred troops
that are being sent in to protect
federal property
and federal courthouses that's not only
their job but their obligation
because they were trying to burn them to
the ground uh
they're not there to restore law and
order to the cities
because the mayors refused to do it what
what do
all of these cities we're talking about
new york chicago
portland seattle los angeles the city of
atlanta what do they all have in common
they've all been run by liberal
democrats for decades
yeah now if you believe as i do and
they'll get into a lot of this in the
book which is over your shoulder
yeah we're going to get there we're
going to get there i promise oh again no
but
but if that actually does this does
color a lot of the stuff in the book
a lot of it it but if you believe in our
founding document our founding document
is our declaration
right some people think it's the
constitution no the founding document
what does it say i can remember it
unlike you know cookie joe
my my favorite clip all these truths to
be self-evident that all men and women
are
created oh by the thing
you know the thing the thing god joe god
every the creator of everything all
right
oh that scared me so but if you believe
in that what what does that line me
we're endowed by our creator means that
god
rights for all of us and i believe this
would
my mind my heart my soul they come from
god
they don't come from man they don't come
from government and
that life liberty pursuit happened
how dave rubin you tell me how do you
pursue happiness if you're
living in those cities and you're not
safe in a park
or your grandma's backyard on the fourth
of july
or if your mom makes a wrong turn on a
city street
uh or if your son is in the summer of
love zone as mayor durkin said how do
you pursue happiness if you don't have
basic law order safety security how do
you pursue happiness
in all of these cities what is one other
commonality
they all have the worst educational
records of
most cities in the world we pay more per
capita for education
than any other country in the
industrialized world
these cities have this income we have
failed our children
if you look at a ladder i used to be a
contractor right you have the rungs of
the ladder
right okay you take away that education
and i'll give you a little my background
i learned latin
i went to a seminary in high school and
the word education from the latin
derivative at dukerne to bring forth
from within
so if we believe that god gives you
rights
if education is to bring forth from what
is already there from god
talents he gave you well you need safety
security you need education
so okay joe biden is saying that the
government's going to take care of
everything you ever want in your life
he's going to take care of a guaranteed
job at a guaranteed wage and
k through college education and forgive
student loans and government guaranteed
vacations and government guaranteed
healthy food
and you're going to have government
guaranteed health care and you're going
to have a
government guaranteed retirement you
don't have a worry in the world i'll get
to the psychology of that
okay what is the track record in these
liberal cities that have been run by
liberals for decades
which is what joe biden adopting
bolshevik bernie socialism and aoc's new
green deal
and and basil bozo as i call him
o'rourke
and bozo's gun confiscation plan
all right so in these cities they don't
give security or safety
in these cities they fail
spectacularly when it comes to education
specific example the city of baltimore
13 public high schools you want to
venture a guess
what percentage in the 13 schools not 13
kids 13
public high schools what percentage of
kids in those schools and you don't have
to answer it's not a trick question
i'll i'll ballpark it i'll try just to
see do you believe
our proficient in math and reading
matt let's start with math i mean i i'm
going to guess
i'm going to go obviously crazily low
it's i'm going to get what's like 10
percent
something like that not one
child in 13 public high schools
baltimore spends they're the third
highest per capita for student spending
in the world not one kid in 13 schools
okay here's the latter why don't you
just take a a sledgehammer
rip out all the rungs and and beat out
both sides of it because
you don't have an education so they
don't provide security safety law order
they don't provide education
all right what else has government done
for us if we're going to put all our
hate if we're going to believe
joe biden and bernie's socialist utopia
and aoc's new green deal
okay and they're going to take care of
every single need we have in life
okay how's social security doing dave
rubin
because the last i check you're screwed
i'll probably get something until they
means test it
because it's headed towards bankruptcy
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell